all right you knew it would happen you
knew
that the conspiracy theories would
explode
thanks to this raid at mar-a-lago that
took place of the failed former
president
and one of those conspiracy theories
that is now spreading like wildfire is
that the fbi planted evidence against
donald trump now is there any reason to
believe the fbi planted evidence at
mar-a-lago against donald trump no
is there any specific claim being made
about what was planted no do we have any
reason to believe that the fbi planted
evidence against donald trump no
but that doesn't stop
them
on the right from saying it the new
trump right-wing talking point is that
evidence was planted this suggests the
reality is almost certainly
that there was no evidence planted and
whatever was found at mar-a-lago is
probably not very good for donald trump
let's look at some examples here is
jesse waters an absolutely
horrible person on fox news
he says the fbi is probably planting
evidence and he goes even further and
says they probably doctored the evidence
to get the warrant in the first place
how horrible is that they could have
easily negotiated the return of
documents like that without guns and
warrants
what the fbi is probably doing is
planning evidence
which is what they did during the russia
hoax
we also have a hunch they doctored
evidence to get the warrant well a hunch
that sounds like it's jesse waters
feeling what's that thing that those
right-wingers always say something like
the facts
don't care
about your feelings and there's a lot of
feelings coming from jesse waters but
very few facts then charlie kirk
interviewed newt gingrich that's a match
made in heaven and again make the
suggestion that the fbi planted evidence
at mar-a-lago do they have any
justification for that claim absolutely
none whatsoever but they're all on the
same page at least as far as the talking
points go uh you really are now seeing
the ugly face
of a tyranny uh and the left is so
desperate so frightened and you're
watching trump win again apparently the
last votes came in and his candidate
beat
another of the people who voted to
impeach him so he's now i think i think
he's now defeated seven of the ten
people with a couple devoted to
impeachment right joking and well in one
case he uh kevin mccarthy talked him out
of challenging uh valedio because they
we wouldn't keep the seat and i think
trump wisely said okay i'm gonna give
him a pass
the next big test of course will be
liz cheney who i suspect will lose by 20
or 30 points uh and she's part of this i
mean she is part of the effort to turn
the system
into a basically a tyrannical
anti-conservative anti-republican
constant violation of the law which is
what the january 6th committee now none
of that's true but here's the key moment
you have a fake committee being covered
by the fake news with a fake fbi uh
which by the way you'll notice they
didn't allow anybody on the trump side
into mar-a-lago so we have no idea
whether or not they planted evidence yes
that's exactly right and and newt i have
a couple of thoughts number one
they have no idea whether they planted
evidence another way to say the same
thing is we have absolutely no proof
that they planted evidence we have
absolutely no empirical basis for
claiming that they planted evidence and
what we do know is that everything about
the uh execution of the search warrant
was handled as it always is arguably
with even more discretion because of the
sensitivity of the individual involved
one other example here this is trump
lawyer elena habba
i don't know where all these lawyers
come from there's so many trump lawyers
this is trump lawyer alina habba
she goes on fox news and she also floats
the idea that the fbi planted evidence
there is no evidence that there was
planted evidence this is a joke this is
momento and quite honestly i'm concerned
that they may have planted something you
know at this point who knows i don't
trust the government and that's a very
frightening thing as an american if i
didn't want to be an american and go to
a nut this is third world stuff we've
heard it this is cuba this is this is
not our country now you know the truth
is
one of the problems with some of the
countries they love to talk about as
third world countries or banana
republics or whatever term they love to
use one of the problems is that there is
no accountability for people in
positions of power and privilege it
distinguishes us if indeed there are
consequences to people in positions of
power and plivers privilege from those
very countries it makes us different
because in those countries you don't see
accountability
donald trump also by the way floating
this idea that evidence was planted he
went on his platform truth social and he
said quote the fbi and others from the
federal government would not let anyone
including my lawyers be anywhere near
the areas that were rummaged and
otherwise looked at during the raid on
mar-a-lago everyone was asked to leave
the premises they wanted to be left
alone without any witnesses to see what
they were doing taking or hopefully not
planting
why did they strongly insist on having
nobody watching them everybody out obama
and clinton were never raided despite
big disputes
folks
not a shred of evidence presented that
anything was planted they will attack
the fbi they're already doing it even
though the fbi director was appointed by
donald trump and trump gushed about how
great his credentials and honesty and
everything was they will attack the
judge who signed the search warrant i'm
already seeing that this morning they
will attack the doj
as a tool of democratic president joe
biden even though the evidence is the
white house wasn't even informed about
this raid they will attack merrick
garland himself which are all they're
already doing they will attack joe biden
which they're already doing and they
will talk about hillary clinton and
benghazi
they will talk about hunter biden's
laptop they will talk about obama i
don't even know why they're talking
about obama i don't understand why you
would rate obama none of it makes any
sense
and they are doing every single one of
those things now later on we're going to
look at a serious case of brain worms
the new thing is
increasingly the next level conspiracy
theory above and beyond evidence was
planted is
this is the beginning of a plot to
assassinate donald trump now if your
plan is to assassinate trump i don't
know why you need to serve a search
warrant first i don't know why you need
to go through the trouble of legally
obtaining the search warrant if your
plan is to assassinate trump it doesn't
pass the sniff test but that has never
mattered to them so we will look at that
a little bit later if you're curious
about some of these clips that we played
during the segment you can find all of
them on our instagram at davidpakmanshow
follow me on instagram at
david.pakman as well